de l'effort physique de l'humiliation
quelques défis le bizutage a longtemps
été incontournable pour accueillir les
nouvelles recrues dans bien des écoles
les bleus étaient de la rue victimes
si peu est tellement consentante et
héros surtout du rite initiatique
le passage est obligatoire mais qu'en
pensent les étudiants 1964 sa vue et une
semaine après 103 sympathique avec nous
une gêne 18h des bandes pas d'esprit
solidarité enfin moi je pense pas il y
assure tous ceux qui ne se raconte pas
devant les caméras
dans cette même école le directeur ne
semble pas ignorer les pratiques de ses
étudiants il y a des tendances chez
certains on veut dire des sévices à des
brimades des humiliations à des annonces
c'est en 1991 que la loi du silence se
brise avec les premiers morts officiels
dans ce document des images filmées par
des étudiants montre la violence
corporelle l'humiliation
la nudité et cela peut aller très long
ils ont arrosé d'un colorant qui j'avais
diluée dans l'alcool à brûler pour que
soit disant de colorants tiennent mieux
qu'on ait plus de mal à le retirer
puis phase a priori indépendante de la
première ils ont approché une bougie
pour simuler le marquage au fer rouge
j'ai été brûlé aux 1er 2e 3e degré selon
les endroits sur 20% nation
aurel c'est dans ce contexte de
violences extrêmes que ségolène royal se
donne pour mission d' arrêter cette
violence on arrivera assez vite à
l'éradiquer parce que le jour où les
auteurs de violence se rendront compte
qu'ils ne bénéficient plus de l'impunité
dont ils bénéficiaient jusqu'à présent
ça sera terminé
depuis 1998 une loi interdit le bizutage
les auteurs encourent six mois de prison
et 7500 euros damende pour autant ce
n'est pas la fin du phénomène
c'est ce qu'explique en 2007 ce
professeur engagée dans la lutte contre
le bizutage la loi de 98 a certainement
changer les choses mais a poussé la
discrétion plus qu'autre chose avant
c'était plus voyants c'est au jardin du
luxembourg c'était au château de
versailles
là ce n'est plus ce n'est plus à ces
endroits là
c'est plus cacher
plus cacher parfois sous le nom de
week-ends d'intégration
ces événements organisés pour l'accueil
de nouveaux étudiants sont à chaque
rentrée le lieu de drame
la consommation d'alcool y est parfois
excessives à l'origine de plusieurs
décès chaque année
quant aux suites judiciaires elles sont
rares le silence pèse encore lourd dans
le milieu étudiant
[Musique]